الينا الان من رفح الدكتور اشرف القدره
المتحدث باسم وزاره الصحه في قطاع غزه
اهلا بك دكتور القدره مع استمرار الغارات
والمعارك كذلك ما الذي تقوله اخر تقاريركم
في وزاره
الصحه بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم لازال
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يشدد من العدوان على
قطاع غزه ويقوم باستهداف مركز لكافه مناطق
القطاع ويقوم بمسح مناطق سكنيه بالكامل
الامر ال الذي ادى الى ارتكاب 16 مجزره
خلال 24 ساعه الماضيه راح ضحيتها 100 من
الشهداء
و313 من الجرحى بجراحات مختلفه وبالتالي
يرتفع عدد الشهداء منذ بدء العدوان
الاسرائيلي في السابع من اكتوبر وحتى
اللحظه الى
26900 شهيد اضافه الى
6549 جريح ولازال عدد كبير من الضحايا تحت
الانق قاد وفي الطرقات لا تستطيع طواقم
الاسعاف او الدفاع المدني الوصول اليها
بسبب منع الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لهذه
الطواقم الانسانيه من التحرك باتجاه
المناطق التي يسيطر عليها وبالتالي لا
تستطيع
هذه الطواقم الانسانيه التوجه الى اماكن
الاستهداف لانتشال المزيد من الشهداء
والجرحى وبالتالي الواقع الصحي والانساني
في داخل محافظات قطاع غزه لا سما في منطقه
خانيونس
للغايه حيث لا تستطيع الطواقم الطبيه
التوجه الى اماكن الاستهداف لانتشال
الشهداء والجرحى اضافه الى محاصره مجمع
ناصر الطب بشكل مطبق وكذلك مستشفى الامل
التابع لجمعيه الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني
هذا الحصار المشدد على هذه
المستشفيات يتسبب في عجز الطواقم الطبيه
القيام بواجبها ووظائفها المنقذه للحياه
حيث تمنع حركتهم
داخل بين الاقسام بسبب الاستهداف المركز
من المسيرات الاسرائيليه واطلاق النار
الكثيف اضافه الى تعطل العديد من الانظمه
الكهرو كهروميكانيكيه وكذلك خزانات المياه
ومحطات الاكسجين سواء في مستشفى الامل او
في مجمع ناصر الطبي حاولنا مرارا وتكرارا
من خلال التواصل مع المؤسسات الامميه
توفير تنسيق لاصلاح هذه الا ولكن للاسف
حتى اللحظه لم ت لم تفلح كل هذه الجهود في
توفير الحمايه للطواقم الفنيه لاصلاحها
وبالتالي يتسبب الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في
اعطال كثيره في الانظمه المختلفه في هذه
المستشفيات وكذلك نقص حاد في المياه
اللازمه سواء للمرضى او للنظافه او او
غسيل الكلى في هذه المستشفيات الطواقم
الطبيه الان عاجزه تماما عن تقديم خدماتها
المنقظ للحياه في ظل هذا العدوان المستمر
وهذا القصف المستمر الحصار المشدد على هذه
المستشفيات حيث ان الطواقم الطبيه لا
تستطيع اخراج اي حاله من الحالات الحرجه
الى خارج المستشفيات سواء مجمع ناصر الطبي
او مستشفى الامل الى المستشفيات الاخرى
دكتور القدره مثل ما قلت عدم القدره على
الوصول الى جم
المصابين وحتى انتشال الشهداء من تحت
الانقاض هل هذا دليل على ان اعداد الشهداء
اعلى بكثير مما تم الاعلان عنه ونحن نتحدث
الان عن 26000 شهيد نعم بالتاكيد نحن فقط
نحصي ما يصل الى المستشفيات بشكل دقيق
ورسمي ولكن الاعدامات الجماعيه التي
ينفذها الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في الاحياء
السكنيه لا سما في منطقه خانيونس كبيره
جدا وبالتالي لربما الساعات
القادمه تكشف عن وجود الكثير من الضحايا
والمجازر التي ارتكبت في الاحياء النيه في
محافظه خانيونس حيث يغلق الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي
كل الاماكن التي ممكن ان ان تصل اليها
سيارات الاسعاف ويمنع حركه المواطنين
وبالتالي هناك اعدامات
كبيره حدثت في هذه الاماكن ولازال عدد
كبير من الشهداء والجرحى
في في الطرقات وتحت القاض المباني التي
يتم نسفها وبالتالي الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
بالتاكيد تسبب في ارتكاب عشرات المجازر
دون ان تصل اليهم سيارات الاسعاف او
الدفاع المدني شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور اشرف
القدره المتحدث باسم وزاره الصحه في قطاع
غزه